good morning ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls welcome to the reopening of
the Oxford Town Hall following its
refurbishment and extension we have
three speakers to address us firstly
April Jones who's a student leader from
Oxford area school mere David is then
our prime minister right honorable John
Key will address us the speeches will be
followed by a wire from the council's
way out a group and then the Prime
Minister will unveil the plaque
the Oxford Town Hall is the heart and
soul of the Oxford community and has
been for almost a century for the
younger people of the community that has
accommodated just goes holiday programs
box box events and I've been told I must
not forget to mention the Saturday night
movies the Town Hall was misplaced all
during its closure and it will be well
years from now on we are indebted to the
Waimakariri District Council amia david
ears for the determination and vision
they have shown and making a commitment
to restore the significant in historical
building the heart and soul of Oxford
returns 1931 of course was also in the
middle of the Great Depression to have
the courage and foresight to embark on
such a major project at such times
testified to the strength to the Oxford
community at that time the cost in 1931
was 4,000 189 pounds the strengthening
and new additions have cost somewhere in
the area of 3.1 million dollars the ANP
Hall on the side of here however proved
to be beyond cost-effective
strengthening so we've taken the
opportunity build a brand new one this
time on the northern end to take
advantage of the Northern Sun it also
meant we got a new and better kitchen
and toilets along with improved disabled
access which meant that the old ramps
could be removed from the front of this
building since the earthquakes a lot has
been happening in Oxford new shops who
emerged a new supermarket is under
construction the school is getting new
buildings and new subdivisions are
filling and we have this town hall so
welcome back the old lady has a new
dress kuro
the township of Oxford and the
surrounding areas have had to make do in
the period of time where the town halls
being closed and that's had an impact
obviously on the local events that that
would have otherwise been hosted here
and they show you that a town halls and
a critically important part of what is a
small community there are a focal point
there are placed we can host things it's
where the kids can come along and have
their price givings and their shows and
all sorts of great things and they are
the heart and soul of a community
they're just important to what makes a
play stack and so to lose your town hall
for the period of time he does resolve
the earthquakes I think is a big blow
actually for Township like like Oxford
and for the year surrounding area and
actually to have it rebuilt and
strengthened and reopen is actually a
sign that you move into the next phase
Oh
you